qui vous a marqué vous isabelle alors
moi je garde las vegas pour plus tard
mais moi c'est le tu l'as vu mon cul de
gérard louvin mais pas n'importe lequel
celui à jean reno
ah ouais alors oui oui tu l'as vu mon
club c'est un jeu qui s'appelle tu l'as
vu mon cul pendant des semaines et des
semaines c'est devenu un classique c'est
bien d'autres conducteurs dire que je
fais mais le conducteur le matin avec
les équipes disais donc le tue l'avion
de mac taylor dont tu l'as vu mon cul
c'est qu'on soit faudrait mettre un
bâton oui mais c'est le prime time un
oui et donc eh oui il a effet à jean
reno et genre et nous lui a fait croire
qu'il était très fâché équipe pour
garder la tête de gérard louis très très
même nous derrière passagers en russie
on en a mais avant qu'il arrive jean des
visiteurs 3 ou 4 3 3 mais tu le fais
parce qu'on m'a dit on attend le feu
vert de avait dit que tu étais super
fâché avec qui avec lui avec qui mon cul
[Applaudissements]
rien
écoute chérie je t'aime beaucoup mais là
non mais c'était là que jean georges en
dehors des gars c'est la non mais c'est
une blague at on des gens c'était une
bague
genre le tout la cifit l'examen c'était
le poste de vie car il engendre
j'aurai dans la classe bravo genre
locaux même temps excellent lorelei
bravo gérard louvin ça a été le champion
toutes catégories où il a vu